I would not describe myself as a businessman.
No,
you're not terrible with that stuff.
But if I did have a business,
I'd want to be a good businessman.
And so I would probably use campaign monitor.
You know why?
Why cause campaign monitor is this company a that allows you to,
uh,
send mass emails to all of your customers.
It gives you useful tools like drag and drop.
It's helps you create personal relational emails.
You were sent a relational email.
Yay.
I know automations.
And you can build relationships with your customers.
That's right.
Sign up.
Try out their platform for free.
I'll try anything for free.
Remember that time I drank ass links?
I was told it was free.
No,
you can actually sign up and try out their platform for free.
No cards,
no contract.
Just do it,
man.
Come on man.
Go ahead and check them out for yourself@campaignmonitor.com slash Conan
campaign monitor.
Make your emails on forgettable.
Ask me what's on my mind.
Sona,
what's on your mind?
Conan was 70 whole food sourced ingredients.
Athletic Greens is the best of the best in all in one whole food supplements.
That's what's on my mind.
It's a powder.
It comes with this whole kit.
You can mix this powder and water.
I'd put it in a,
you know,
a little vodka in there.
Maybe you know,
defeats the purpose.
No,
it doesn't.
It's for nutrition.
So why can't you have nutritious a alcoholic beverage before he go to sleep?
All I'm saying is you do with this powder what you will,
but this is good stuff.
Now we have a deal for our listeners.
We can get 20 free travel packs flat.
It's $79 with your first purchase,
go to athletic greens.com/conan to claim your special offer today.
Get in the daily routine.
You've got the New Year,
you've got this powder,
you mix it up and then you drink it down.
Go,
go,
go.
And then you've got all that good stuff in you and I'll tell you something else.
I was surprised at how quickly it dissolved.
I always look at patterns.
Say you're dissolving too slowly.
This one before I got to your design.
It was already dissolved.
That's a fast dissolving powder faster than I expected.
Hi,
my name is Mark Marin
and I feel um,
nervous about being Conan O'brien's friends.
Hello there.
And welcome to Conan O'brien needs a friend.
Pretty simple idea.
This is the show where I Conan O'brien talk to people.
A lot of them I've known for many years.
They've been on my show many times.
I'm just trying to find could we be real
friends,
not just on the air talk,
show pals,
but real friends.
And I'm aided in my quest by my trusty assistant sona most [inaudible].
Hello.
I am Don Quixote and you are my son show panzer.
Okay.
I am Batman.
And you're my Robin.
Okay.
Right.
I Guess Fair?
Sure.
Yeah,
I don't,
Robin's not as,
he's not cool.
He's not interesting.
You're not brooding like Batman,
but I'll,
I'll take it.
Yeah,
no,
you're,
you're definitely,
he's chipper you.
Definitely.
Robin,
maybe you're Robin and I'm back.
You think you're Batman?
I think I'm pretty cool.
I do.
Okay.
It's weird,
but okay.
I guess I'm Robin to your Batman Cause I think of Robin as Batman's assistant.
The way you're my assistant.
Yeah.
But I'm going more by personality.
Like Batman is cool and Robin is like not as cool.
Okay.
We'll talk about that later.
Also aided by my producer Matt Gorley.
Matt,
you do all kinds of stuff and I don't understand it.
Uh,
you put things through filters,
you touched various buttons.
You have levels.
Uh,
what do you do?
I'm the Alfred the Butler of this.
Oh,
your outfit?
Yeah,
I'm living there in the podcast cave.
Just keeping things wearing a Tux,
keeping things tidy.
So your Alfred Sona is Batman and I am a Robin.
Yes.
It seems to be doing a lot more work than Batman,
that's for sure.
Yes.
In this context.
Well,
what a weird,
uh,
Tria we are,
but we're working together on this quest to find friends.
Today we're going to talk to someone I've known for a really long time,
Mark Marin.
Uh,
mark has been struggling in the podcast space and maybe this will give him a
little bit of a boost.
He could use it.
Yeah.
Anyway,
I'm thrilled he's here.
Mark Marin,
why would I make you nervous?
Well,
yeah,
I think you're relatively nervous and I'm kind of a guide that has limited
boundaries.
So I pick up on your anxiety.
You pick up on my side.
Yeah.
You're making me yelling or ready because every time that you have come on the
show.
Yeah.
And it's been 25 years.
Just coming on the show.
I think you've been on the show more than anyone else next to Al Roker.
Yeah.
You and you're in the,
you're in the Al Roker League,
so congratulations.
He's a lot more happy than me whenever you're on the show and after all these
years,
you're saying that I make you nervous?
A little.
Yeah,
but not like not in the way where I'm sort of like a,
I don't know if I'm going to be able to do this or if he likes me or something.
It's just that you're pretty amped.
So I got it.
I got to get amped and uh,
sometimes when I get amped it,
you know,
it's hit or miss with me.
But with Roker your do you put that on me?
You're putting your whole personality on me.
You're a neurotic guy.
You're an anxious guy.
Yes.
You are not a settled zen guy.
That's right.
Suddenly you're,
you're here saying,
yeah,
I'm that way because of you Conan.
I no,
I'm just saying you that you amp it up.
Well,
I amp it up.
I think I'm very calm.
I'm a very calm guy.
Even how you say calm is making me anxious.
SONA.
Yes.
Am I calling that?
I don't know.
I'm not so now no.
Alright.
Are you calm?
You would just say I'm a calm centered.
No,
I would not say you're a car.
I think you're pretty,
I agree with mark.
I'm sorry.
I am.
I'm tightly wound.
Yeah,
I think you are.
You should,
uh,
well that was nice.
But maybe no more of you during this conversation.
Do you remember?
Um,
one of the first times I have to be honest that I think that I deserve,
I should be,
even though me and Al Roker have,
uh,
been on roughly the same amount of times,
maybe him a little more is that he has this built in thing every,
every other or every two appearances with Roker you could go like,
wow,
you lost the weight.
See with me fresh every time.
Yes.
Yeah.
You,
I have to come up with a new idea every single time I talk.
Well,
you kind of wait for me to,
uh,
to kind of start it awkwardly.
Yes.
I know.
I never understood why that happened though,
even though it became a thing with us.
I do want to understand why.
Here's the brilliant thing about you.
There are many brilliant things,
but um,
that was just a kind of like,
I like it.
Here's what is amazing about you.
25 years.
You've been on so many times and every time you come out,
every time you'd come out,
and this is back way before WTF way before you were Mark Marin,
the podcast God,
the Mark Merrett before I became a middle level celebrity that half the people
knew you were hot,
you were above mid level.
You are high,
mid level.
Yes.
I'll take it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Long before all that,
you would come on my show do panel and you would always dig a hole.
You would dig a hole in front of the audience.
I know,
but you would dig a hole.
The audience would turn on you and you would always dig your way out.
I know,
and I don't know how you did it.
Well,
I mean that's the way I work.
That's how I create,
but I never planned it.
I always thought when I got out there,
whatever my idea was to start the thing with was just going to nail it.
Every time.
I'm amazed.
I get out there,
see,
I don't know if it's my energy or my reacting to your energy as we've already
established where I,
if it's a tone thing,
but I put the first thing out and then nothing,
and then you look at me and then it's like,
yeah,
you did it again.
And then I got to look at the audience.
Go Really?
And then that then yes,
but you will always turn on the audience and you would acknowledge that you
would start it badly and you would do this every scene,
every time.
And I'm telling people out there listening to this,
you can go online and look up Mark Marin appearance from the beginning,
from 1993 almost to the present.
It's always the same.
You go out,
you say something,
you shouldn't say,
uh,
we planned it.
Maybe we didn't.
Maybe that was my,
no,
you would freestyle,
freestyle and you would say,
you know,
the Nazis give him some credit for,
and then bang,
the Nazis were antiabortion.
Right.
Something like that
now.
Yeah.
That was something like that.
You know,
they,
Hitler built the Autobahn.
That's a good way to get around it.
Well,
it would have been the other way.
It would have been the Nazis were pro abortion.
Like there was a good thing about the Nazis.
You just oils pro choice.
You just don't know if it's true.
But I'm just trying to make an example and now I just did what I did on the
show.
Everyone out there.
Thanks.
I just did it again.
This is you.
What you are antiabortion that's what they think right now.
Just hearing that quip.
No,
that was not the point of it.
See,
this is how it happens.
See the dynamic that's unfolding and then you have to save me and then I can get
back on track.
That's why it happens.
So you can save me so you can look good.
I'm going to tell you something.
What I,
uh,
been been,
been very happy for you because the podcast exploded.
You are on the Mount Rushmore of podcasts.
It's your face chiseled into a mountain next to Ira Glass next to Sarah
Canaigre.
Uh,
I mean these are,
this is huge.
I restarted,
he was a radio guy first.
They just got it loaded up his radio show onto the podcast platform and he found
success because he already had it.
I would like him to be removed from that mountain weight.
You're throwing shade at Ira Glass.
Oh hell y'all throw shade.
I glass.
Okay.
How can you just talk like that all the time and act like it's going to be good
for 30 years anyways?
No,
I love IRA.
No you don't.
You know,
he'd feel you did it.
You know you have some resentment towards IRA glass is not a good time for me.
He started in radio and then just shifted over into potty.
He didn't shift.
They just put his radio show on there.
Yeah.
And so you really helped develop this format.
Exactly.
You helped create this format.
Yeah.
No,
you,
you are a giant in the podcast.
Yeah,
I'd say that like on the mountain.
Oh,
a little,
a little more hiking up to me from where I was noses.
Okay.
That's,
yeah.
No,
no.
Let me say this more clearly.
Irs sort of towards the bottom of the mountain.
He's how you access the mountain.
You step over his face to then start climbing the mountain.
Then when you get to the top,
there you are,
Mark Marin.
I would say that everybody who like I think what I ever did and what Pete,
what NPR has done,
what everyone's done with podcasting is anything that brings people to the
medium to getting it to the,
to the access it.
Cause there's a whole generation of people to this day,
my father who I think is lying,
can't figure out how to listen to one of my shows.
But that's a whole other,
you know,
if we want to talk about that,
there's,
we're going to have to get some of these people out of here.
So why?
Because there's a personal and I wanted it,
you know,
that's what you do.
I know him and you go d sometime you go deep and you get inside.
I'm not going to do that on this point and I'm surely,
but uh,
but no,
I'm happy for anybody who brings people to the medium so they have choices.
Okay,
well diplomatic and I love IRA.
I've listened to his show several times.
I get moved.
It's always a good story.
You never know where it's going is obviously we created something amazing,
but it didn't start as a podcast.
Yeah.
I have respect for him.
Sure.
You ended with the passive aggressive resentment.
Okay,
here's what I want to say.
Yes,
you have this podcast and I had such respect for your podcast and I went on your
podcast and it's revered at that for that reason,
and there were many people that said to me,
cone,
and you should have a podcast.
You have a quick agile mind.
You have a smooth,
uh,
speaking voice,
you should have a podcast.
And I said,
no,
I won't do it because I have a TV show.
Mark has the podcast.
Then you betrayed me.
God,
listen,
you got Marin,
the TV show.
Yeah.
Okay.
That wasn't enough for you then glow.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
You have two TV shows in a podcast.
That is why I'm starting this podcast out of spite.
Out of spite.
Why should you have two TV shows in a podcast in me?
Just a TV show.
Yeah.
No,
I get that.
And I,
and I think,
uh,
all right.
Checkmate.
I guess.
Yeah.
I guess I win this round on that buddy.
I guess you got in at the right time.
There's only 90,000 podcasts.
Is that true?
I was told there were very few of these.
I was told by my people that this timing is perfect.
Right?
Right.
At the point where people have had enough of podcast,
you're launching one.
I think that's great.
I was told I was assured by my people that there was you and like one other and
that was it.
Just the 10 on now on a high tunes that are listed in the top 10,
that's the only ones that exist.
Don't ever scroll below that.
Uh,
this is news.
This is news to me.
You're doing a great job already.
Listen.
Yeah,
I,
I respect you.
You make you a master at this format.
Yeah.
What's your advice?
Is there anything you could tell me about a podcast?
Are there things I should avoid or,
or,
or there are things I should be doing or how do you prepare?
Give me some advice.
We've been friends a long,
well not friends,
but we've known.
Do you remember the advice I gave you?
Right.
And like the first year of your show,
like one of my first appearances,
it was so funny cause I was in a different place in my life there.
And uh,
and I told you before I go on,
I told you my mantra,
which was hide the hate and you sort of took that with your high day by the Hay.
Well that's also a I,
that's a very Irish Catholic thing.
We hide the hate.
If you hate someone,
you tell everyone but that person that you hate them,
but you never tell that hide the hate and display the shame.
Right.
That's the Irish Catholic,
right?
Right.
Yes.
Uh,
advice for podcasting.
I don't know.
For me,
I don't,
I I prepare like my,
I see your notes,
my notes look more like just your handwritten ones.
There's never any type things with me.
And I usually just do bullet points or scattered 'em I do almost like a weird
collage of bits and pieces I want to know about.
So it starts to look like the inside of my brain.
So I don't have any ordered way of,
of sort of asking questions.
I just have a bunch of ideas about the person or bits.
Like if somebody cured cancer,
you don't want to miss that one.
You should probably involve that in the conversation.
Like I tried to,
big achievements or things are known for.
I'll throw that on the list I'm looking through here for you brought up podcast
and to answer a lot of Conan's.
He already did it.
You did it naturally.
Want us say you didn't see,
you don't have any curing cancer and,
no.
Let's see.
Yeah.
It says here you got a Latin grammy.
See that's,
this is good.
Podcasting.
You're not prepared.
It's a human moment.
You're looking for your Pi,
your pages.
I,
there's a rough edge to it.
Like a lot of times you heard my neighbor working on his yard.
Occasionally people would knock on the door sometimes.
When Andy Richter was on,
that was,
uh,
that was what got me to get an air conditioner.
Like Andy came on and it was summer and it was in the garage and I had not put a
unit in the window yet.
And Andy almost died.
I don't know if he's talked about that publicly,
but I'd never seen a person sweat more than that.
And after that I'd got an air conditioner at Helms had a cat allergy.
I didn't think that the cats would trans,
you know,
there was no cat ever in the garage,
but he was wheezing a 40 minutes in.
And uh,
I needed an hour.
So it was,
uh,
it was hard to listen to Ed wheeze and watch his throat type.
Now you should know because you're carrying a lot of guilt here and these are
things we should do.
I've got an air purifier is what I'm saying.
And that's what got me to do that someone did in Andy Richter sweats and a snow
storm,
you should know that he had good,
and number two was Ed Helms has tuberculosis.
Oh my God.
Yes.
I don't know bad any.
No.
Great loves cats.
So it was not allergic to cats.
He played Banjo I think,
and he was like,
it was a 10 Helms played banjo.
I believe so.
Am I making that up?
No,
it does play Banjo.
That's what he does.
That's his thing is he plays Banjo.
He did.
He played some Banjo.
My recollection from Steve Martin,
I believe that's all Steve does now.
Right?
Apparently I wanted to have him on the show,
but he was like,
only if we only talk about Banjo and I'm like not doing that.
You said no to Steve Martin.
I did.
No,
you don't do that.
I did.
Wait a minute.
What?
No,
you say yes to Steve Martin.
He let him do what he wants to do and then do I need to get it in?
Exactly.
I know I know the game,
but he like he,
there's something about him that intimidates me.
There's a few people that I have on.
I don't think it's ever going to happen,
Steve.
I think it would have a good conversation with,
but he was just in this period where he had written a book about stand up and
that was the end of it.
Now it was all about Banjo and I got nothing against Banjo.
But like,
then I got to fight.
Then I got to have a Steve Martin who seems a little depressed.
Anyways,
we're talking about Banjo and then I go like,
when you first got on stage as a standup,
he's like,
like,
I didn't want to deal with that.
Usually what happens with older artists,
I've found like,
let's take Roger Waters for example,
from pink Floyd.
Yeah.
Some of these guys,
they,
they're out promoting a record,
which is sometimes the only way I can get them.
And he gets in there,
he's like,
look,
I don't want to talk about pink Floyd.
And I'm like,
Oh,
Christ.
All right.
So this happens all the time on my show.
Yeah.
I don't want to talk about the only thing I'm known for.
Right.
And then he gets only thing.
And you've only got like 11 minutes.
Yeah.
And the,
so it's like Eli Whitney invented no,
no cotton.
And then he comes on.
And just before,
uh,
just one thing,
it was just not,
talk about the cotton from cotton.
Anybody knows about you,
Eli?
No,
no,
no.
I'm working on something new.
It's a shoe.
No one cares.
No one cares about your shoe.
He cotton shoe.
You know,
I've had so many,
so many times and it's the publicist,
people have publicists,
publicists always says first line of defense,
you know the publicist.
Oh he says,
you know that thing that's really funny that my client was going to say that
it's hilarious and it's going to totally kill and it's going to go viral.
We're killing that cause we're going in a different direction.
They're going to talk about linoleum.
Exactly.
Well No,
with Roger,
what ultimately happens is you realize that they do want to talk about it cause
they've been talking about it their whole life.
And for some reason they just think that that,
that the new thing they're doing is the best thing they've ever done because
they have to.
Yes.
And you know,
you just work it around and like within seconds,
uh,
you know,
Roger Waters was throwing David Gilmore under the bus and I'm like,
I didn't even ask for this.
Right.
Uh,
did you find him to be a little bit of a sour ball?
He's angry guy.
Yeah.
That's the same thing.
Yes.
I interviewed him once and he was incredibly sour and tense period.
Then daddy's stuff.
Yeah,
he's sour.
Was No fun to talk to.
I'll throw him under the bus.
I don't care.
I'm not going to run into him again.
And so I,
yeah,
but I won't recognize him.
Uh,
and no one does.
That's one of the problems.
Could you recognize any of pink Floyd?
Almost every band that you've liked their entire life you would recognize but
like him?
Yeah,
I don't,
you wouldn't recognize David going out on the street.
What'd you,
I might ask him.
I don't even know what the drummer's name is.
And they're a huge band.
Isn't that weird?
It's weird that we don't know their faces,
but I want to throw Roger Waters under the bus because he was a sour ball.
And then we go to commercial and you know,
in commercial that's usually when most guests,
there's a friendly has changed and out of a lineup you always say to lean over
and go like,
that was pretty good.
Right?
That was okay.
That's what you always do.
Cause that was,
I was,
I wonder if you're listening dude.
Was that okay?
Was that good?
What did you think?
Was that okay?
And,
and it's always like,
I,
okay,
I got to take care of mark here.
Yeah,
exactly.
But the guests,
so we throw it,
we throw to commercial,
but they pay back.
That band's playing and Roger Waters turns to me and he goes,
that's it.
And I said,
uh,
yeah,
that,
that was the end of the interview when he went,
then this is me leaving and he stood up and walked out.
Oh.
So I see why you have the prize.
What is that?
That's a guy that got a,
you know,
tricked into doing your show.
Didn't really want to do it to begin with.
I think he thought he was doing Alan.
I don't know.
I have people I can look like Ellen from a distance,
but I find that with these guys,
those guys,
those older dude,
especially musicians like I,
but some of them accept it.
Like Neil Young,
I didn't know was a difficult interview.
No one told me I should have done some homework.
Right.
So now I've got to pull teeth and thank God he tried to figure out
mathematically how many nicotine lozenge as I do and he got a real kick out of
the equation and we were kind of rolling from there.
It turned out to be good interview.
That's the key to podcasting.
Don't plan the conversation,
don't plan a conversation.
And Nicotine Lozenge.
I was off them for a while.
I'm back on him.
We don't need to talk about it.
Oh,
when someone says don't talk about it,
I say let's talk about it.
Oh well yeah,
it's just a cycle with me.
I got off,
I'm like,
I haven't smoked a cigarette.
And like over decades,
it's been a long time.
I was on a nicotine Los Angeles for a long time,
uh,
because I enjoy them.
And then I found,
you know,
dipping and get just getting any nicotine anyway I could,
and then I'm like,
this has got to stop.
And I stopped everything for a few months and I thought,
well,
maybe I'll have a cigar.
That would be nice.
And then within weeks I'm smoking two a day,
I can't breathe.
And then I got to get off the cigars and then we're back on the loss and just,
and it all starts again.
Conan could,
God,
it's the joy,
the joy of just all sort of addictive behavior.
Didn't,
no,
no.
I'm getting now.
It's just time to get off.
Just end it now.
And what the addiction or all of it.
It's the whole thing.
The time to just start off you first time you do it,
I'll do it.
Shuffle off that morning.
All suffered enough.
I,
what was I going to tell you,
man?
They gonna tell you some other things that will help you take your life.
That's what I'm going to,
Oh,
I'm on it.
I'm doing it.
I'm actually doing,
dude,
I've been exercising a lot and went to the doctor.
Everything's pretty good.
Wait,
so,
uh,
you went to the doctor.
I know that you were very phobic about easier your health.
Not Bad,
not bad,
not as bad as it used to be.
Well,
wait a minute.
You,
you had a big prostate scare.
You told me that.
Yeah.
You told me once that you had a prostate.
I thought I had it.
It's always,
that's the,
they've was,
it made you feel that you had a prostate skip?
Just too much time on my hands.
But what was there any symptom?
It may be like,
what have I got to think about?
Pride,
Diana?
Something.
I'm at that age.
Maybe we should go to the doctor and get one of those exams.
That'll wake me up.
You voluntarily went and had a guy put his hand on your ass?
Not the whole hand.
Where do you go?
Oh,
I got a guy that does two hands if you tip them.
Yeah.
That's,
that's a hell of a show of hands and a heel.
Yeah.
He gets all kinds of stuff in there.
Uh,
I'd pay him top quality.
Sure.
Shirts.
A doctor.
Do you know what?
It's funny he doesn't,
he's not dressed like a doctor.
You might want to check out.
Really Weird and it's not at diploma.
There's no diploma.
Yeah.
It got me thinking that,
you know,
we have to do what?
We have to take an ad break.
Is that how you're going to do it?
We're going to take an outbreak.
You can do your own reeds or you're going to drop ads and I do my own ads.
But you don't do them later or you can do it now.
I'm not gonna do it now.
Oh,
I don't want you,
I don't want you looking at me while I do an outbreak because the only way I can
do it and really feel good is her naked.
And so I get it.
But the naked between radio and podcasting,
it's like when you do a radio show,
you gotta sit there and watch them do the thing.
Hey,
how's everybody?
Yeah.
One of Vermont.
Teddy bear.
You like Teddy bears?
Vermont.
Teddy bear is a big advertiser.
Back in the day that was that true?
Yeah.
On Teddy bears.
I said the Alex Bennett used to do it when I was doing that show in San
Francisco.
I did radio for awhile.
You know,
I tried to take an ad break and it's impossible if you take an app or a no,
no,
no.
I didn't take an ad break.
But you've had 45.
What's throat lozenges wrote to the ad break?
Uh,
throw it to the bank to do it.
You think you can stop for a second?
Hey,
what is,
uh,
what would you like your audience to bike on it?
Oh my God.
I can't wait to tell you,
but it seems like you've got more to say about something.
Oh,
I have a lot more to say.
Boom.
Add break right there.
I've got it.
You know what?
I did it and I screwed it up.
Yeah,
I was trying to help out.
Let's get to that.
I break that.
See,
he can't be the last,
he can't let me be the last one to talk.
You can just cut it.
There's guys,
oh no,
nope.
He's going to go
away.
No,
no,
no.
Well,
I'm keeping all of this,
but just give us the ad copy.
Let's read it now.
They don't have it.
What?
Yeah,
it's an advertiser that's on the fence until we got Marin.
It's true.
You know what it is?
It's a,
it's a company that sells nicotine lozenges.
Good.
I wanted you lag.
Yeah,
they did.
Hold on.
We'll take a break
and now it's time for a segment called Conan.
O'Brien pays off the mortgage on his beach house.
Yup.
I'm an adult.
Took out a big mortgage,
made some sketchy financial choices,
but I'm a big boy and I'm going to pay the pay the Piper and I'm going to pay
them bills down,
paid them bills,
pay them bills.
When you hear crazy fun facts,
Sona,
I'd love to,
there are a lot of hotel rooms out there that just sit empty,
waiting to be booked,
but people don't know about them.
Don't you wish there was a way they could know about them?
There is a way that was probably too aggressive,
that was way too strong and not used to this hotel tonight.
I Love Hotel tonight and now you've used hotel tonight.
I've used it before.
I would,
you know we got paid to you.
Uh,
no.
I love this APP.
I use this APP in light.
So what is it?
So if you need a hotel on short notice,
you pull up hotel tonight and it gives you deals for whatever hotel rooms are
available in whatever area you're looking for.
So if you're like,
hey,
I'm in.
I just happened to be in Santa Barbara and I don't have,
sorry,
this sounds like a hookup.
What it does,
it sounds like a hookup.
I mean,
if you meet someone in a bar and you're like,
let's find a hotel.
You pull up hotel tonight and you could,
wow.
Oh my God,
I would not be cool enough to do that.
I would fumble from my phone,
accidentally take a Selfie,
which would immediately,
and then the phone would explode.
I just,
it would all go wrong.
I wouldn't know how to do that in that situation.
Oh,
so wait,
so hotel tonight,
this sounds like you're very excited about it.
I saw it as a truthful person.
She nuts.
She always tells the truth to a fault.
I love this.
I love this app a lot at shows you cool hotels in your area and they give you
profiles of each hotel.
This one's short,
this one's tall.
This hotel has Benny windows.
This hotel has none.
It tells you stuff like that.
I'm going to point this out because I think they want me to point this out.
Hotel tonight's not just for last minute bookings.
Oh,
book way in advance.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
they've only booking,
but you just,
I mean,
now you're married so there's no hookups,
but I could still go on trips and stuff.
I was like,
you're about to say could still have hookups.
I need to say,
Sonya,
you can't.
You took a vow.
I was at your wedding.
I could go on trips.
Spontaneous weekend getaways.
Three Day weekend.
You're reading the paper,
read trips,
business trips,
booking a place with a pool and more.
I could still do all that stuff.
Oh my God,
they got to you.
I've never seen it.
Well,
anyway,
a hotel tonight sounds like you know what?
This is the most enthusiastic I've heard you about anything that we've talked
about.
I think that this is the most enthusiastic I've been of any of the stuff that we
advertise.
Am I allowed to say that?
Probably not,
but you just did.
I mean cause I used it before we got paid for me to use it and stop saying we
got paid.
I'm sorry.
I mean but
point.
We're doing this because we love these products.
We believe in them.
I really do love this one.
So to start scoring amazing deals at incredible hotels.
Go to hotel tonight.com or download the APP now.
You already have the,
I already have it.
That's so amazing.
Yeah.
I might get this APP hotel tonight.
Get that APP,
get it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Bang.
We're back.
Wow,
that was quick.
Yeah.
Great job on that Ad.
Then I do a good job.
Excellent.
I put my own personality into it.
It was great.
I wish I could remember what I wanted to bring up earlier.
It doesn't matter.
No,
it does.
As I get older you,
I forget a lot of things.
I walk into rooms a lot now and I don't know why I came into the room.
Then my wife comes in the room and I'm like,
who are you?
It's just,
it's scary.
It's frightening.
Might want to go back to that doctor.
I'm like,
God,
I lived that done.
He put an alarm clock up there once walked.
Yeah.
I walked around with it for four weeks.
It was a fantastic experience.
Um,
I uh,
I wonder why maybe you can answer this because this is part of the point of my
podcast.
We'd known each other 25 years.
I like you.
I have a lot of respect for you.
You always make me laugh,
but we're not friends.
We're not friends.
No,
I tell I've talked about that in particular with you.
Yeah.
Well there was that.
We don't hang,
we don't have,
do you hang with anybody?
I mean,
where you get to a certain age,
you've got kids,
you've got a wife,
you've got a house,
you've got other things to worry about.
You probably need time just to kind of freak out about shit.
Yeah.
But like how you got to really make time for people.
But I remember when you did,
my show is near the beginning and I appreciate you doing it.
And I had done your show many times.
You've always been good to me.
I,
you know I've always been loyal to the show and we had that dynamic and then you
come over and you'd do the podcast and afterwards,
because I wrote about this,
I think I already talked about on the show,
you kind of hung out for a little while and after a certain point I'm like,
oh he's got to get out of the house.
Yes.
Okay.
Like I don't,
we don't do this.
Picked up on that.
I checked up on that because I did your podcast.
I enjoy your company.
I'm in your home.
I am in your home and you started getting anxious and then you started trying to
get me to the door and I was offended.
I was offended.
Yes.
Cause I thought why not sit down?
Did you fail it and,
and,
and offer me a piece of Pumpkin pie would have if I had pie.
You're not a guy that has pumpkin pie around ice cream.
I used to have ice cream back then.
I might've had pie.
I've had to feed people before so I had to feed people and it's supposed to be
something that you do with love and generosity,
not a chore.
When people come over,
they don't eat properly.
Jon Glaser came over once and he was starving.
I made him a sandwich,
gotten Roseanne came over once and she needed something.
I gave her cantaloupe.
People hated it because she was eating cantaloupe on the,
on the mic.
That's a disgusting sound.
When someone needs cantaloupe,
Rosanna talking or you know what I,
that was very good.
That was very good.
I'll get any points for that,
but I want to tell you why did you want me out of the house?
I'm a good guy.
I clean up nice.
Oh No,
no.
It was nothing like I didn't want you to have the house.
I just didn't know know.
I'd never been in that situation with you like every time,
like here's what my experience with you.
I come,
I go to the dressing room.
Jimmy gives me a guitar,
I play it.
You come in and say hi,
what's going on?
I see out there,
I go out there,
we say thanks and and yet over the years it's gotten warmer and and then then I
go away.
So there we just talked for an hour by your life and your childhood and then
you're in my house and I'm like,
I've never had it leave much taller here than he is on the set and we were just
talking and it was awkward and I thought like,
you're lectured me out.
You ushered me out.
Nobody.
Then we actually acknowledge it.
It's like it's weird that we don't hang out.
I don't know why we went and hung up,
hang out.
You want to hang out.
I got a lot of people in my phone that I've done on the show that had been on
his show,
but do I call them?
No,
the only guy,
this is why I want to talk to you is that for 25 years I've been talking to
three guests tonight.
They're there to promote whatever they're promoting and we look friendly on the
air.
But then I don't hang out with them afterwards.
Plus probably better than I had a party not long ago and I looked around and
everyone at the party is someone on my payroll.
The only people that came to my party,
our people I pay.
Did you invite other people?
I didn't get an invitation to see,
maybe this is the problem.
No,
I didn't invite you.
You didn't.
Well,
because here's my theory.
My theory is that we aren't peanut butter and jelly or peanut butter.
And then on the more acidic peanut butter were like,
like skippy with sugar and then just a chunky rock kind.
Yes.
And you put both of those together and there isn't even,
there wasn't even bread.
You're just eating it with your hands and it's a freak show in your mouth is
clicking.
Yeah.
I have no water.
Yeah,
that's true.
I think we have a certain similar energy.
Yeah.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
you have a lot more in your head than me I think.
Do you think so?
I think naturally your brain,
like mine is completely everything that's going on in my head.
You know,
I'm the center of,
I think that you sometimes can kind of look at other things and improvise on
that with me.
I have to be like,
what?
How does that affect me?
And then I have to go through that way.
So I think you have a more active imagination that's probably a little more
palatable.
I just looked that up online.
That's called narcissism.
Yeah.
Why fight that you,
you're losing.
No,
I'm not.
You're losing it.
I'm not,
I'm not a narcissist.
My father was,
you know,
you wait.
So you think you are not a narcissist.
You just said anytime you want to talk about anything you have to relate it to
yourself and how you're the center of the universe yet.
But I'm aware of that.
So that makes me not a Marxist.
So what serial killer can narcissist a narcissist?
Yeah,
you can know a serial killer can know he's a serial killer,
but if he continues to kill in the Pacific northwest,
he's still a serial.
Yeah.
But like he likes that.
I don't particularly like this part of myself.
Okay.
You don't know because like I,
you know,
my dad I think is really actually a pathological narcissist.
I think everyone's a little self centered and a little narcissistic.
So I have shrapnel from that upbringing and behaviors from it.
But it's not,
I don't have a blind spot,
you know,
I'm not,
I have shame,
I have guilt,
I have a conscience full of empathy.
So all that stuff that the self centerdness element is that I tend to think
about myself a lot because I'm neurotic,
right?
So when I think about things outside of me,
it's,
it has to do with my life,
with its effect on me.
I,
and I think it's helped my comedy to be honest with you,
because there was a point,
and you know this to be true.
When you're doing jokes and they're written and they're topical you,
you know that the other talk shows are going to do similar theme jokes.
Yup.
So that's the same with up.
So once I was able to untether myself from observational or political comedy and
just focused on me,
no one's going to steal.
I defy someone to do my material because it's all about me.
And if you're that much like me,
then I'll talk to you after the show.
I have to say a your,
this is totally making sense to me because it's,
the thing I liked the least about doing a show right now is when there's this
pressure to be topical.
You talk about Trump because everybody's doing it.
So I find much more joy in comedy that has nothing to do with what's talk about
your own experience.
Right.
So that's what I started to do on a very conscious way of level.
And maybe I,
it,
you know,
I took to it pretty well and I can integrate a lot of cultural criticism or
whatever and talk about current events,
but I have to do it,
you know,
from my point of view and not from jokes.
Yeah.
So it was a,
it was a great,
um,
it was,
it was good for me to,
to realize that yes.
Can I be really honest with you?
The other reason I don't think we hang out is that over the years you introduced
me,
Oh,
this is the woman I'm with,
you know,
and I sort of start to try and form a bond with her and then she's gone.
Cause that happened over the years.
Pretty clever transition.
Well I saw what he did there,
but hasn't it,
it was a period of time where you were like,
you had a few of my made two of the wives and most of the girlfriends that have
come,
I'd met them all.
I got them all.
And you know what,
I'm afraid to form a bond with them because I don't know what's going to happen.
Yeah.
But you know what about me?
What about the bomb with me that see,
we still got it.
You know,
I think you've,
you've dealt with friends who have had women.
I happen to know,
uh,
you definitely know people who've had a few women come and go.
Yes,
I have.
But uh,
but yet,
believe me,
I had a harder time maintaining the bond with those women that,
that you did,
but you were,
you're much quicker.
And making me think.
I think I formed a deeper bond with those women.
Probably 20 seconds we talked.
And a you manage whenever you found out in 40 seconds sometimes took me years
and a lot of money to figure out.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a liability.
You know,
the,
the relationship thing.
Anytime you're with someone and is maybe could be the foundation of a new
friendship.
Anytime you start to date someone,
have me meet them,
happy,
meet them alone,
like the third date.
Look,
I just have Conan's going to meet us at the restaurant first date,
first date.
First date.
You say before I can see you,
you have to meet Conan O'brien.
Man.
If I was single,
this could be a segment dude.
Uh,
it could have been a segment.
It could be.
Again,
you never know.
Um,
oh,
thank you for the vote of confidence.
Sorry,
I've just been through this too many times,
you know,
but no,
I'm,
I've been with the one now for like four years.
It's been going pretty good.
I'm very happy for you.
But that,
but that's not like it's a good sign.
But the two wives,
the,
those were about eight,
eight and a half years.
And then there was that.
As long as the marriage should last I,
but then there was the one that before this one,
the three year one,
that was probably what that would,
if she would have made me not want to be someone's friend.
Really.
I don't know what happened to her,
but you know,
wait,
we're both wives.
Eight years.
Did you say about,
yeah,
three and a half married and then I was with them for a few years before.
Yeah.
That is so interesting because I'm married and eight years into my marriage,
my wife looked at me and said,
I think I'm good.
Yeah,
I'm out.
I think I'm good.
But we still,
we were still together.
You know,
it's still together now.
Yeah.
So how do you get past that hump?
Well,
she just realized I'm a good earner.
She get to everything you wanted to on your notes.
I,
you know,
you keep saying,
I have notes and I really don't.
These are recipes.
Oh,
can I have one?
Says,
I'm looking for some new recipes for thanksgiving.
Um,
but you know what?
You would be awful on thanksgiving.
I'm great at I,
I couldn't be terrible.
I cooked for 22 people.
Do you even know them?
Do you have their family?
And I didn't do it for a couple of years because I was shooting quo and also I
didn't want to deal with the a Republican contingent,
but I'm going back for the first time in like three years this year and we've,
we've brought the number down.
But I,
I'm the guy who cooks the entire thing.
That's so crazy because you don't have,
you have the opposite of a holiday energy.
Here's how I get into the holiday spirit.
I make this amazing spread and,
and then,
then I walk around and this will,
this will ring true with you.
I walk around because you know me this way.
I walk around and go like,
how was it this year?
Pretty good.
How's it stuffing?
Right.
The best.
Yeah.
How did I do?
Did I do okay?
Thanks.
Giving dot died.
What did you think of me doing my thanksgiving?
Right?
How did it get over it anymore though?
Cause I've gotten some confidence.
I'm not as insecure as I used to.
You used to be so I don't,
I don't fish for it.
I wait for it.
What if you don't get it?
And I know when you're waiting for it,
your legs jiggling,
you're popping,
uh,
you know you're popping mentholated lozenges,
cinnamon ones.
There's cinnamon four milligrams.
Did you ever smoke a lozenge?
Just out of desperation?
Oh sure man,
I got,
I got him for that light,
I hope.
Yeah.
Different light up a lozenge and just suck on it.
And I snorted him.
I snorted the loss and she's this,
we should do that sometime in an hour.
Lawson's I'd do that with the saddest thing.
I remember years ago,
this is the story that I've never told man.
Maybe I've told it once,
I don't remember years ago,
back in the day,
come in and this might not make the cut we have,
we have very low bar.
Well now I was with the,
I was with Matt,
it was back when I was still using drugs and,
and we had been drinking all night.
Me and this guy,
Matt,
and we're back at the house where I lived with a bunch of other dudes and we'd
run out of drugs and we had run out of wicker and we were chopping up,
we were grinding up,
you remember vibrant wasn't called by front,
the yellow pills,
which at best is equal to two cups of coffee.
And we were snorting vibrant.
So there was like are the guide yellowness caked in our nostrils and it's like
two in the morning and Bob comes home from work after being a waiter and he
looks at us,
he walks into the kitchen,
he's like,
are you snorting vibrant?
What you're snorting [inaudible] and he just shakes his head and goes to bed.
It was a,
it was one of those moments where it was like,
I,
this is stupid.
This is a new,
this is a new low.
We just apparently wanting to snort something didn't matter when.
I'm glad you mentioned vibrant because the good folks at vibrant,
great,
amazing product,
great and vibrant Lawson they bought into Brian needs a friend.
Yeah.
And uh,
that was perfect the way you segwayed into it.
I love talking to you.
I really do.
And,
and uh,
I'm very honored that you would stop by my podcast.
As I said,
you are the master of this form and I basically got you here to ask you one
simple question,
which is,
well I make money.
I think he will.
I think you'll start out with a pretty good crowd and like,
you know,
it was over there.
You guy that.
Um,
but you think I'm going to make some cash?
Yeah,
I do.
I don't know if it's cash or you're used to,
but I think that you'll see what the numbers are and then you sell the numbers
cause I need,
you can't need money.
I fucked up.
You did.
I fucked some stuff.
You're one of those guys.
He overextended.
Where's the second house?
It was a few problems.
Boat.
You've got a boat.
There was a boat.
It was,
I'll say that.
Well,
so I got excited about two years ago about theme restaurants and I went into,
and I went in,
I went in big on theme restaurants.
I did not consult anybody.
I did not consult my wife.
I did not consult my business manager and lost it all.
And I'm sorry,
there was a theme restaurant in the valley,
a whole chain of them.
It was a new idea.
And the whole idea was,
you know,
that some of them are like 1950s themes.
This was a depression era themed restaurant and cause you have to go wearing a
barrel.
Did the wait staff where a barrel,
that was one of the ideas.
We rejected that because we thought it was impractical,
but it was a lot of just depression era themed music was playing.
And uh,
we mostly just served apples and it tanked.
No good.
And I went in,
I didn't know,
you're not supposed to put your own money and here's what's,
Oh yeah.
So I'm sorry.
No,
I think you'll do okay.
You know what,
what happened if I said to you,
I think you'll do okay.
You'll spiral,
but we would,
you would spiral,
wouldn't you?
If,
hey,
next time you're on the show,
if I went back behind backstage in the green room and you went as a crowd and I
went,
I think you'll do.
Okay.
That's pretty,
you would just turn into a puddle,
a Mark Marin puddle.
I think you're going to do great.
I feel like that your account now.
I think it will be okay.
Uh,
honored to have you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah,
thank you.
That was fun.
Fine.
You didn't it everything.
You didn't take a whole no,
I didn't.
I just,
you know as,
again,
these are just Paula Deen recipes.
I'm trying to figure out if I ever have any questions for you.
You can ask me a question.
Why don't you ask me a question and you're the podcast
that's not necessary.
It's not wow.
What a good work ethic.
Yeah.
I think it was how you approach everything in your life.
Huh?
Well,
I have a question flush that toilet question,
but it's sort of serious and I don't think there's an answer to it.
And,
and I think that,
uh,
you know,
I'd processed it and it's a little heavy.
There is a god,
there's a heavy,
it's a little heavy.
It's all personal and it's a little heavy.
You want me to ask it?
Yeah.
Okay.
So when you hosted the tonight show,
yeah.
Why aren't you have me on?
Why didn't I have you on the tonight show?
Yeah.
Because it only lasted for 45 minutes.
I didn't get to you.
Okay.
I,
this is so many people that weren't on that tonight show because I mean it was a
bad time.
They're understanding there are an apple will rot faster.
Well,
I think what it was like for me at that time,
I,
you know,
it's probably not great.
Do you realize we didn't get,
there was not a lot of time that we were on the air and um,
you took,
this is amazing.
You took my losing it tonight shill and made it about you.
Wait,
that's,
that's that.
No,
that is not an interpretation.
That is what you did.
I was excited that you got the show.
I was all,
I was always on the other show.
I was like,
this is going to be great.
I've waited.
I didn't do the tonight show with anybody else and I'm going to do with my pal
Conan and I should be on in the first week.
The no fee?
No.
Why?
Well because we had pearl jam will Pharrel we,
I mean I'm sorry.
I'm sorry you weren't on the first week and I think in my head I was thinking,
can't wait to have mark on because you know what they say about tonight?
Show host once you name it tonight,
show host,
he lasts as long as he wants and then you know what happened?
That didn't happen.
And so I never got to you because there wasn't enough time and I apologize and I
wish now if I could get in a time machine that you are my first guest on that
tonight show.
Thank you.
I didn't mean it.
I know you'll do okay here and I feel terrible now.
You feel solid or friends?
I didn't want to bring it up,
but I was just,
I just like,
I dunno.
I wanted some closure or something.
I forgot that I had the resentment until this morning.
You resent that I didn't have you on the show.
It's over now.
It was on for,
yeah,
and I'm sorry about that.
Sorry.
Can you see me all choked up about it?
No,
no.
This is better.
You know,
if I had my choice between the tonight show or a podcast,
this is clearly the one I tell you.
This is clearly the way I go.
This is the hardest I've seen you laugh actually in a while.
Well,
I'm honored to be one of the first guests on the podcast.
if this is,
this is anything like,
hey,
you know,
this may be one of four episodes I got in under the wire.
You know what's going to happen in six weeks?
Why Jay Leno is going to get this podcast.
It's going to do a,
it's going to do it from a fire engine or a car.
An interesting format.
How they work.
I just talking to how do they see me
thing?
I see the car.
It had nine felonies.
No one knows mine heaven.
If I'm fine.
This is good.
We're sweating it out.
We're sweating out the toxins.
All right.
I don't say this often,
but I love you.
You're a great man and I thank you so much.
I really am.
Thank you for,
I really am honored.
Thank you so much for me to leave that last part again.
Time for another installment of Conan O'brian pays off the mortgage on his beach
house.
Watch the old show.
Gilligan's island.
I do.
They made everything on a bamboo.
The professor could make a radio out of bamboo Gilligan,
could make a bicycle out of bamboo.
They lived in bamboo huts.
Everything was bamboo.
There's one thing they didn't think about it on that island,
making clothing out of bamboo task performance made that dream that they never
had indoor reality.
Wow.
It's a weird sentence.
Task performance was brought to life in 2009 with one goal,
invent revolutionary fabrics to reinvent performance apparel,
and they did it because everything's made from bamboo.
That means it's better for the environment because you can grow.
Bamboo grows quickly.
I don't know how you make clothes out of it.
They do tasks,
knows exactly how to make clothes out of it.
Most of the things that we've done ads for,
you don't know how to do if I say so go out and get that heart surgery right
now.
You never weigh in and go,
I don't know how to deal heart surgery,
who we know.
You don't know how to make clothing out of bamboo,
but task does and they do it brilliantly.
They harness the bamboos natural performance qualities.
They make this silky smooth,
great fabric.
I was just saying this today to one of my kids.
I was telling them tasks,
Pim,
a lux fabric brings together the luxury of Pima cotton with the versatility of
bamboo performance technology.
My kid was like,
what are you talking about?
And I said,
just listen to me.
I'm talking about PMO.
Lux Fabric,
settle down
and you notice got,
that's important for me.
It's got UPF 50 plus protection.
Yeah,
with superior breathability because not only do I burn easily,
but I emit many odors,
so it's just a great product.
Bamboo.
Who'd a thought,
right?
I wouldn't have you ever look at bamboo and go.
That would make it really great fabric.
Yeah.
I don't know how they made radios out of it either.
Oh,
the,
they just nailed them together.
Anyway,
it's exciting.
You can probably tell by the way I'm talking to task.
Performance is good stuff.
It is.
It's good stuff.
It's exciting.
It is.
Pima Lux fabric brings together the luxury of Pima cotton with the versatility
of bamboo performance technology.
If I've said that once,
I've said it a thousand times,
um,
and they sent us some stuff,
which is really nice.
I felt it and if it felt silky and it felt breathable,
it doesn't feel like a tree.
Oh my God.
You're the worst.
You think that should be their slogan.
It doesn't feel so I'm of Sassy and says it doesn't feel like a tree.
That's right.
It doesn't feel like a tree.
And Joy.
15% off your order and experience superior performance wear
today@taskperformance.com.
That's t a s C performance.com.
Enter Conan at checkout.
And remember with task,
you won't feel like a tree.
Okay.
It's time for a new segment called ways in which Conan is like Freddie Mercury.
Now why I'm bringing this up because Sonia's is absolute hero in show business
businesses,
Freddie Mercury.
And I'm hard and I'm guessing I'm number two.
And so one of the ways in which I'm like Freddie Mercury,
not at all,
not even in little talking about,
I'm a great,
I'm a great showman.
Well,
I mean the way you're a great showman in the way Freddie Mercury was a great
showman,
are very different.
What's the difference?
Uh,
he was the best front man of a band ever.
And uh,
you dance like a club.
My God,
I'm sorry.
No,
you,
you are great at what you do,
but you can't compare yourself to Freddie Mercury.
I saw the movie about Freddie Mercury,
the bio pic,
Bohemian rhapsody.
Okay.
I saw Bohemian rhapsody and I watched it and what I thought when I was watching
it was there telling my story.
Oh boy.
That's what I felt.
How do you think you are?
Like Freddie Mercury.
He was born with extra teeth and that gave him this incredible,
which felt like a disadvantage.
But then it also gave him this incredible,
uh,
multi octave range.
Okay.
I was born with a certain body and certain,
uh,
fidgety mannerisms,
and,
uh,
strange hair that ha and a weird first name that all were disadvantages when I
was a child,
but then made me the greatest front man in the history of rock and roll.
Boy,
you almost had me until the end and I think,
you know what,
here's what I'm going to say.
I think you would be just as funny in a different body because it's your brain
that makes you funny.
But it's hard to argue that it's not his teeth that gave him the range that he
has.
I think that my career has gone through many of the ups and downs that Freddie
Mercury's did.
And I think that,
uh,
I was the voice of a generation
worldwide in the 70s and into the 80s.
You think you are a voice of a generation in the 70s.
You were like in your teens.
Anyone was listening.
Oh,
you were just talking to yourself.
I have my version of,
I think when I go to comicon and do shows there,
it's like Wembley.
Oh,
okay.
And I think it means as much to a worldwide audience.
Do you think you make comparisons?
You compare yourself to people like I dunno,
I mean just going off memory.
People like Jesus and William Shakespeare and the bottles.
Oh,
you'd think.
Okay.
All right.
Well I feel like I'm a talking.
My father could have been a carpenter.
Ah,
I um,
I have apostles,
meaning writers.
You look at your writers,
his apostles.
This podcast is my sermon.
A lot of similarities.
Do you think you're a little ill?
Uh,
yeah.
All the way Picasso was ill,
ill,
the way Mozart was ill.
So you're saying I'm sort of like Freddie Mercury,
just not completely like Freddie Mac?
No.
I said you're nothing like Freddie Mercury.
I can sing like him.
Do you have parties that are just full of debauchery or are you like,
here's,
here's my wine.
Well,
if it's inappropriate amount of wine,
you don't want to have more than a glass.
Maybe two,
two glasses at most because then there's the sugar and uh,
also with dehydrates.
So make sure that you drink three glasses of water for every glass of wine.
I'm sure that's something Freddie Mercury did and I'm sure he watched his
cluster all the way.
I do.
And I'm sure he was really good friends with his college roommate and they
talked about Theodore Roosevelt a lot.
These are things,
ways in which Freddie Mercury and I are very similar.
Oh boy.
Anyway,
I get it to best showman that you've known in your life.
Freddie Mercury,
Conan O'brien.
Who's to say who was actually the better showmen Freddie Mercury?
Well,
you can think about it more if anymore.
Freddie mercury,
Freddie Mercury.
So we'll get your final decision.
Okay.
Freddie mercury,
Freddie Mercury.
No,
she's mulling it over.
Freddie mercury,
Freddie mercury await Freddie mercury,
patiently
Freddie mercury,
Freddie mercury becoming soon Freddie mercury.
So it's a tiny
Conan O'brian,
needs a friend with SONA,
most Sassy.
And then Conan O'brien as himself,
produced by me,
Matt Gorley,
executive produced by Adam Sachs and Jeff Ross at Team Coco and Collin Anderson
and Chris van.
And at Earwolf.
Special thanks to Jack White and the white stripes for the theme song,
incidental music by Jimmy Levine.
You can rate and review this show on apple podcasts and you might find your
review featured on a future episode.
Got a question for Conan,
call the team coco hotline at (323) 451-2821 and leave a message it to could be
featured on a future episode.
And if you haven't already,
please subscribe to Conan O'brien needs a friend on apple podcasts,
stitcher,
or wherever fine podcasts are down.
This has been cocoa production in association with.